Das Rasenfunk – Tribünengespräch.
Ich möchte mich beim SPIEGEL, bei Klaus Brinkbäumer, bei Alfred Weinzill, aber insbesondere bei meinem damaligen Ressortleiter Michael Wulzinger dafür bedanken, dass sie mir für diese Arbeit mit dem Whistleblower so vertraut haben. Man muss sich das so vorstellen, da geht ein durchgeknallter Reporter in das Ressortleiterzimmer und sagt, ich möchte jetzt nach Osteuropa fliegen. Ich kann dir nicht sagen, wohin. Ich kann dir nicht sagen, wann ich wiederkomme. Ich weiß nicht, ob auch nur eine einzige Zeile davon am Ende in unserem Blatt erscheint. Und übrigens, die Chefredaktion darf nicht wissen, wo ich hinfliege, weil das habe ich dem Whistleblower versprochen. Es darf in keiner Reiseabrechnung vorkommen. Und dann ein Nicken zu bekommen und vorm Ressortleiter gesagt zu bekommen, pass auf dich auf, ruf an, komm wieder.
Ich möchte mich dafür einfach bedanken. So fing es alles an mit einem Nicken, mit einem Macht's gut und Komm gut wieder. Wir hörten den Journalisten Rafael Buschmann vom SPIEGEL, Autor des kürzlich oder ganz neu erschienen Buches Football Leaks. Und das Zitat entstammt seiner Dankesrede bei der Wahl zum Sportjournalist des Jahres. Und ich freue mich sehr, dass ich ihn hier im Rasenfunk im Tribünengespräch der Ausgabe Nummer 10 zu den Football Leaks begrüßen kann. Schön, dass du mit dabei bist, Rafael. Wir wollen heute über die Football Leaks sprechen, aber nicht zu zweit, sondern wir haben auch noch Nicole Selmer mit dabei, stellvertretende Chefredakteurin vom österreichischen Fußballmagazin Ballesterer mit ihrer Rasenfunk-Premiere. Nicole, ich freue mich sehr, dass du auch Zeit dafür hattest.
Also wir haben aus der Fußballbranche selbst von immer noch aktiven Fußballern nahezu nur Schweigen geerntet. Auch auf Anfragen nur Schweigen geerntet. Wir haben im Zuge der ersten Football Leaks Berichterstattung im Dezember ein Interview mit Gianni Infantino geführt. Das war für mich ein gerade Beispiel, wie ein Mensch sich auf Eis bewegt und unter seinen Sohlen nur Butter hat. Also dieser Gianni Infantino, der wackelte, der schlitterte, der versuchte sich herauszuwinden mit Phrasen und Worthülsen und sagte in wirklich blumigsten Worten immer wieder, wir werden uns das genau angucken, wir werden uns überlegen, wie wir damit umgehen, wir werden. Dass kritisch beurteilen passiert ist, genau nichts. Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass irgendwas aus der Branche passiert, dass diese Branche sich in irgendeiner Form selbst reglementiert. Das wäre auch ziemlich dumm, weil alle an dieser Branche wahnsinnig viel verdienen und jeder, der – auch wenn es nur der kleinste Berater ist – jeder, der daran verdient, hat kein Interesse daran, die Hand, die ihn füttert, zu beißen. Von denjenigen, von denen wir einen irren Zuspruch und auch Anfragen erhalten haben, waren Steuerbehörden. Steuerfahnen. Unsere Quelle, John, unser Whistleblower, ist direkt in den ersten Tagen der Veröffentlichung über die Homepage bombardiert worden von Steuerbehörden, die sich bei ihnen gemeldet haben, die um Auskunft erbeten haben, die teilweise mitgeteilt haben, dass sie seit Jahren schon hinter bestimmten Konstrukten her sind, die ihre Verzweiflung ausgedrückt haben, wie sie an Briefkastenfirmen scheitern, wie sie an Auskunftsgesuchen in der Karibik oder im Nahen Osten, in China, wie sie daran einfach scheitern, wie sie dort nicht weiterkommen. Da haben wir schon gemerkt, wie viel Druck eigentlich auf dem Kessel ist und wie viele Steuerfahnder die Probleme sehr deutlich sehen, aber überhaupt kein Werkzeug haben in unserer aktuellen Gesellschaft, diesen Machenschaften irgendwie auf die Spur zu kommen. Die sind schlicht und ergreifend verzweifelt.
Das ist eigentlich auch eine schöne Geschichte. Unerkannte Helden, die Steuerbehörden.
Die sehen, dass sie am Ende wieder ausgetrickst werden, egal was sie machen. Wir sehen ja auch an den Daten, es gibt einen niederländischen, argentinischen Spielerberaterring, der die ganzen Geschäfte hier in Europa macht, teilweise mit echten Topstars. Die Topstars werden hier beraten. Und diese Spielerberater schalten Strohmänner dazwischen, die für sie dann die Verträge mit den Spielern abschließen und die Honorare werden dann an diese Strohmänner weitergeleitet. Diese Strohmänner behalten von diesen Honoraren dann 2000, 2500 Euro, wie auch immer, und leiten den Millionenbetrag weiter an eine Firma auf den British Virgin Islands. Das ist dann die Firma, für die sie honorarmäßig gearbeitet haben, der Geldfluss geht raus. Wo werden dann diese Millionen versteuert? Natürlich auf den British Virgin Islands, mit 0 Prozent. Das haben wir uns sehr gut angeguckt, weil wir dann auch am Ende jemanden gefunden haben, beziehungsweise unsere Partner von NRC Handelsblatt haben, unsere EIC-Partner von NRC Handelsblatt in Holland, haben diese Person gefunden. Das beschreiben wir auch im Buch. Das ist ein Poet, ein Dichter. Er schreibt Poesie. Er hatte mal zwei schlechte Jahre. Seine Bücher sind nicht gut verkauft worden in den Niederlanden. Wie auch immer ist er in diesen niederländisch- argentinischen Spielerberaterring hineingestolpert über einen Freund, der gesagt hat, hey, das ist total schnell verdientes Geld und du kriegst dann keine Probleme. Das ist schon sehr lustig und blumig, wie er beschreibt, wie dann irgendjemand ihn mit einem Auto abholt. Er bekommt einen Aktenkoffer in die Hand, in dem zig Dokumente drin liegen. Er sieht diese Dokumente aber erst Stunden später, weil er selbst darf diesen Koffer gar nicht aufmachen, sondern er wird zu irgendeinem Rollfeld gebracht an einem Flughafen, wo ein Privatflugzeug landet. Es steigt jemand aus, der Koffer wird aufgemacht. Die Dokumente werden ausgetauscht, die er unterschrieben hat. Er muss sie dann einmal unterschreiben in seinem Namen, dass er dieses Honorar erhalten hat. Dann werden diese Dokumente gegen andere Dokumente ausgetauscht. Er macht den Koffer wieder zu und fährt wieder nach Hause. Das ist Mafiastoff. Auf diese Art und Weise laufen Geschäfte im Fußball ab. Wenn man diesen Menschen gegenüber sitzt, sagt er, ich versteuere hier alles ganz sauber meine zweieinhalbtausend Euro. Ich bin auf der sicheren Seite. Wir stehen vor diesem Gebäude, bei dem wir wissen, hier läuft die Kohle aus Europa drüber, über einen Ring, der sich über verschlüsselte Kanäle unterhält, der über verschlüsselte Kanäle genau dieses System erfunden hat und über dieses System kooperiert. Das macht etwas mit einem, das ist ein ungutes Gefühl und wenn man dann feststellt, wenn Steuerveranstalter dem ganzen auf die Schliche kommen, dann passiert Folgendes. Diese Firma wird einfach abgewickelt, sie wird einfach dicht gemacht, die ganze Kohle aus dieser Firma wird rausgeholt, sie wird nach Hongkong überwiesen oder nach Dubai. Das ist jetzt rein hypothetisch. Ich müsste jetzt Buch gucken, um genau zu sagen, wohin das Geld überwiesen wurde. Auf jeden Fall wird diese Firma platt gemacht, der Strohmann verschwindet und der dahinter liegende Strohmann verschwindet auch. Danach geht das Geld wieder auf Reisen und der Steuerfahnder in Europa darf das nächste Rechtshilfe ersuchen, an ein anderes Land stellen, was dann vielleicht wieder zwei oder drei Jahre dauert. Solange diese Jungs keine Fehler machen, solange sie genau solche Experten haben, die dieses Geld durch die ganze Welt schießen, hat ein europäischer Steuerfahnder überhaupt keine Möglichkeit dahinter zu kommen und sich dranzuschauen.
Oder solange man das nicht irgendwie belegen kann, was ja jetzt durch die Football Leaks passiert ist und was ich sehr interessant finde, ist, dass, so wie ihr das im Buch schildert, hinter John stehen ja mehrere Menschen. Es ist nicht klar, wie viele und erst recht weiß man nicht, wer und wo die alle sitzen. Aber es ist ein Netzwerk und noch während ihr den ersten Kontakt hattet, hat dieses Netzwerk immer neue Dokumente bekommen aus allen verschiedenen Richtungen. Am Anfang konzentrierte sich das sehr auf Portugal und Spanien und viele Fälle hat mit Spielern zu tun, die zumindest mal in Spanien gespielt haben. Aber dieser Datenschatz, wie du ihn nennst, ist immer weiter angewachsen. Wird denn da jetzt dann noch mehr kommen in Zukunft? Denn das hört sich ja so an, als ob wir es hier nicht mit – wir haben zwar einen John, der ja überall immer John heißt – John Doe, das ist ja quasi ein Max-Mustermann. Aber es wirkt so, als ob wir dahinter ein Netzwerk, vielleicht Organisation, etwa eine Gruppe von Menschen hätte, die jetzt aktiv gerade weitere Dokumente sammelt. Meistens wird es noch weitere Leaks geben.
Also ohne das Ende des Buches zu spoilern, das möchte ich nicht, kann ich glaube ich sagen, dass wir weiterhin weiteres Material bekommen, dass wir auch in den letzten Wochen und Monaten daraus neue Geschichten gemacht haben. Eine der Geschichten sind die Vergewaltigungsvorwürfe, beispielsweise gegen Cristiano Ronaldo, die eine völlig eigene andere Geschichte sind, eben aber auch aus diesem Datenschatz stammen. Wer hinter Football Leaks am Ende steckt oder wer Football Leaks ist, kann ich bis zum Schluss, also bis zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt der Recherche trotz, ich glaube, hundertfacher Nachfragen nicht beantworten. Ich habe bislang mit einer einzigen Person zu tun gehabt, der ich versprochen habe, dass ich sie in der Anonymität lasse. Wer ansonsten an diesem Netzwerk mitarbeitet, kann ich schlicht und ergreifend nicht seriös beantworten. Ich kann von meinem Treffen mit John berichten, wenn ich am Ende von ihm in eine Wohnung geführt werde, die aber eigentlich ein Büroraum ist, wo unterschiedliche Türen geöffnet stehen, beziehungsweise einen Spalt breit offen stehen. Ich sehe diese Menschen dort in den Zimmern, ich sehe sie teilweise in der Küche. Ich weiß nicht, ob es seine Mitbewohner sind, ob es seine Freunde sind, ob es Arbeitskollegen sind. Das verrät er mir nicht. Sie sprechen nicht mit mir. Wir müssen eher wie Geister, die da über die Flure huschen. Das macht das alles auch nicht ganz so einfach für uns, weil man am Ende eine sehr, sehr weiche Quelle – so würden wir als Journalisten das ausdrücken – hat, bei der man keinen Anfang und keinen Ende hat. Man weiß nicht, wie sich das Ganze strukturiert. Man versteht die Organisationskultur dahinter. Was ich, glaube ich, verraten kann, ist, dass John immer wieder sagt, sollte es jemals in Bezug auf ihn zu einer Verhaftung kommen, ist dafür gesorgt, dass dieses Football-Leaks-Modell weiterhin aufrecht erhalten wird. Er hat mir mal eine Art tickende Zeitbombe gezeigt, weil wenn so ein Button in seinem Computer nicht bedient wird, dann beginnt Football Leaks automatisch, die Daten hochzuladen. Es gibt Sicherheitsmechanismen, die die Organisation beziehungsweise die ER getroffen haben, die dazu führen, dass sein Datenkonvolut nicht in Vergessenheit gerät, wenn es ihn mal nicht geben sollte.
Football Leaks hat ja auch über die eigene Intention immer mal wieder Auskunft gegeben, auch im Buch, und das wurde auch vorher schon veröffentlicht, und da schreiben sie, Zitat, unser Antrieb ist es, all denen das Handwerk zu legen, die sich zu Unrecht an dem Volkssport Fußball bereichern. Wir wollen zudem eine neue Ära im Fußball einläuten, die Zeit der Transparenz. Und jetzt hast du ja schon ganz gut beschrieben, Rafael, und das wird auch noch mal eindrucksvoll, und da wird man sehr wütend an dieser Stelle des Buches beschrieben, wie die Verbände und Vereine reagiert haben nach Football Leaks. Spoiler, es ist nicht so, dass wir jetzt eine neue Zeit der Transparenz haben. Stelle ich mir die Frage, Rafael, was kann man da denn jetzt tun? Denn diese Wut, die lässt einen nicht los, wenn man von diesen Summen liest, wenn man das immer mal wieder hat, man im Buch so Momente, wo man sich denkt, ach, der kriegt, hat jetzt nur 400.000 für den Deal bekommen, das ist ja fast wenig. Und dann überlegt man sich, Moment mal, wie viele Jahre müsste ich eigentlich dafür arbeiten? Aber das hatte ich wirklich immer wieder, weil einfach diese Summen so hoch sind. Jetzt ist die Frage, wohin mit meiner Wut, Rafael, was kann ich denn tun? Was kann der Fußballfan tun?
Ich glaube, da überfragst du meine Kompetenzen als Journalist bzw. Das muss jeder für sich selbst beurteilen. Ich glaube, ich würde mich schlicht und ergreifend nur auf das konzentrieren wollen, was wir enthöhnen können bzw. was wir aufzeigen können. Du hast vorhin eine interessante Sache gesagt, wie die Verbände reagiert haben. Für mich ist immer noch das Highlight Karl-Heinz Rummenigge, der sich in einer HCR-Sitzung furchtbar darüber aufregt, dass die Atmosphäre in der Umkleidekabine durch die Football Leaks ein wenig ungemütlich wurde, weil die Spieler sich über die unterschiedlichen Gehälter unterhalten haben.
Das war eine der Stellen, die ich meinte. Da bin ich sehr wütend geworden.
Genau. Da geht es nicht mehr darum, können wir uns eigentlich reflektieren. Ist das noch ein Markt, der irgendwas mit den Menschen zu tun hat, der ihnen bezahlt? Sind wir immer noch auf dem richtigen Weg mit einer Branche, die anscheinend keine – nach oben hin – Bereiche weiterhin für einen offen hält? Müssen wir hier keine Ahnung, einen Salary Cup einrichten? Müssen wir nicht Transparenzhäuser wie ein Clearinghouse für Berater etablieren? Ich habe eigentlich erwartet, dass vielleicht der ein oder andere kluge Geist aus dem Fußball sich mal dazu einlässt. Das habe ich alles nicht gehört, habe mich dann aber versucht, zurückzuerinnern, wie das beispielsweise bei der FIFA zuletzt war. Und da muss man ja ehrlicherweise auch sagen, da reden wir, ich weiß nicht, jetzt auch seit zig Jahren über Reformen und Reformkonzepte, die da entstehen. Die FIFA-Ethikkommission und eigene Ermittlungsbehörden, die im Verband aufgebaut wurden, am Ende hat man gesehen, wer Transparenz in diesen Verband gebracht hat. Ermittlungsgruppen, das FBI, die Schweizer Bundesanwaltschaft, die Frankfurter Staatsanwaltschaft, die Justiz, die dann auf Basis von Hausdurchsuchungen, die auf Basis von Whistleblowern, wie im Fall des FBI, die Kronzeugen bekommen hat, die auf diesen Grundlagen angefangen hat, im Fußball zumindest für einen Übergang in eine neue Zeit zu sorgen. Ob dieser Übergang tatsächlich ein Übergang zur Transparenz sein wird, das wage ich nahezu noch dem, was wir bislang beschrieben haben, ein wenig zu bezweifeln, wenn Uli Hoeneß in Lichtenstein darüber fabuliert, dass man zukünftig womöglich in China Fußball spielt und jeder Chinese einen Lieblingsspieler hat und dann für nur ein Dollar sich ein Stream oder sonst was aufs Handy holt. Bei 300 Fußballbegeisterten sind es mal schlanke 300 Millionen. Da braucht man keinen rechten Künstler mehr zu sein, um zu verstehen, welche neuen Märkte da gerade erschlossen werden sollen und in welche Bereiche der Fußball vordringen soll. Ich neige mittlerweile auch dazu, dass ich kaum noch Grenzen der Absurdität in meinem Kopf generieren kann. Ich habe mir vorgestellt, was eigentlich noch in den kommenden Jahren auf uns zukommen kann, wenn man dann irgendwann mal so auf so ein Spiel zwischen RB Leipzig und RB Salzburg im Champions-League-Finale stößt und das Gefühl hat, vielleicht werden ja noch vier weitere Mannschaften in dieser Champions-League spielen aus der Mateschitz-Imperium. Wer sagte, dass er bei diesen beiden Mannschaften aufhört, wenn es so einfach ist, einen Champions-League-Teilnehmer zu kreieren und sich dann überlegt, wo eigentlich dieses Geld herkommt, was er dann da hinein investiert und dann den nächsten Schritt macht und sagt, Oligarchengeld, Geld aus China, von irgendwelchen Investoren, bei denen man keine Ahnung hat, wie sie ihr Geld eigentlich gemacht haben. Das sind ja alles Faktoren, die irgendwann auf diesen Fußball zukommen werden, wenn er sich so weiter entwickelt, wie er sich entwickelt. Und ich glaube nahezu aus dem Lesen der ganzen Zahlen und dieses Wahnsinns, der auch in Spanien und in England, also in unseren unmittelbaren Konkurrenzländern des deutschen Fußballs gerade entwickelt wird, kann man ja fast davon ausgehen, dass auf uns in den nächsten Monaten eine ziemliche Debatte über die 50 plus 1 Regelung zukommen wird, die schlicht und ergreifend dafür sorgt, dass wir möglicherweise in Deutschland nur über finanzielle Exzesse, aber noch nicht über die ganz extreme Form von Illegalität sprechen, weil wir da eine Bremse noch installiert haben. Aber auch das ist ja nur eine Frage der Zeit, wann auch das in Frage gestellt wird, damit Vereine dann aus ihrer Sicht wettbewerbsfähig bleiben können. Ach herrje, Nicole, das ist ja so eine ganz fiese Partybremse, so komme ich mir hier vor.
Ja, das war jetzt nicht das optimistische Schlusswort.
Ja, also dann kann ich mir ja wirklich nur noch hier den Freizeitkick im Park um die Ecke angucken, weil alles andere ist, das ist ja furchtbar deprimierend. Nicole, kannst du mir sagen, was können wir Fans denn tun? Wir sind doch auch nicht komplett machtlos. Letztlich kommt ja das ganze Geld, oder viel, viel Geld kommt von uns durch Merchandiserlöse, die wir verursachen, dadurch, dass wir ins Stadion gehen, dadurch, dass wir unter anderem durch so tolle Produkte wie den Rasenfunk – ups, sorry – Fußball zu so einer tollen Sache machen, dass man dafür Milliarden an TV-Geldern verlangen kann. Irgendwie steht das ja schon alles im Zusammenhang zum einzelnen Fan, aber irgendwie ist man auch total hilflos.
Ja, also genau, jetzt mit dem – ich habe jetzt die Lösung oder?
Bitte, bitte!
Champions-League-Finale, komm, also DFB-Pokalfinale, eh das allerbeste. Ja, ich glaube, ich glaube, dass schon auch, wie Rafael sagt, dass die, also du musstest eh dann für dich selbst die Wege finden und dann auch, aber natürlich auch teilweise nicht allein. Und das, ich, ich würde schon auch sagen, dass sowas wie Rasenfunk und ganz viele, also da kannst du ja tausend Beispiele finden, was jetzt Fans tun, die eben dann nicht, Entschuldigung, Bayern TV gucken, sondern eben ein eigenes Medium zu machen. Das ist ja auch schon sozusagen in diesem System irgendwie zu bleiben, aber sich darin auch, also darin ein bisschen Sand im Getriebe zu sein.
Ja, aber andererseits steige ich doch so nur die Berichterstattung über die Bundesliga. Ich wollte es jetzt auch gar nicht nur auf den Rasenfunk beziehen, so wichtig nehme ich die Podcast jetzt nicht, aber wenn es die Bundesliga jetzt von einem Tag auf den anderen nicht mehr gäbe, dann hätte ich ja auch ein Problem. Ich versuche ja gerade vom Rasenfunk zu leben.
Ja klar, nein sicher und natürlich, aber ich glaube, das ist einfach, das haben wir ja vorhin auch schon ein bisschen, also ich glaube, das ist halt auch der Widerspruch, der da ist. Also den natürlich sagst du dir, also da machen ja auch Leute schon oder da kannst du ja auch sagen, okay, diese WM in Russland und WM in Katar, das gucke ich mir nicht an. Ich bin nicht Teil von, ich finde, das sind falsche Entscheidungen, es sind Länder, die nicht meiner Vorstellung davon entsprechen, wie eine wenn es Nationen dann schon geben muss, wie die funktionieren sollten und da bin ich jetzt nicht Teil davon. Ich falte jetzt nicht ein, ich teile diese Berichterstattung nicht, ich interessiere mich nicht dafür. Das sind ja Dinge, die man irgendwie tun kann, die sich dann vielleicht auch lächerlich anfühlen oder auch unangenehm. Man fühlt sich komplett uninformiert und isoliert, was weiß ich. Weiß ich nicht, vielleicht wird das auch so aussehen und ich meine, das passiert ja auch. Also es passiert ja durchaus auch, dass sich Leute vom Fußball auch abwenden. Also ich glaube, es passiert einfach noch nicht in einem besonders spürbaren Maße oder es wird derzeit einfach auch noch durch genug anderes aufgefangen. Aber das scheint mir jetzt auch nicht so ausgemacht zu sein, wie das weitergeht. Also ob das Modell Hoeneß, also was Rafael eben noch mal skizziert hat, also ob diese Zukunftsvision dann auch tatsächlich funktioniert, wenn das Fundament, was eben im Moment für den Fußball halt noch hier in Europa irgendwie auch tatsächlich ja teilen, weil zumindest noch in den Stadien gelegt wird, wenn das irgendwie nicht mehr da ist. Also da weiß ich nicht, ob das auch eine naive Hoffnung ist oder eine zynische oder sowieso irgendwas, was auch gar nicht eintreten wird. Also das ist ja auch schwer zu sagen. Aber ich finde schon, dass es diese Bewegung, ob man das jetzt resignativ macht oder auch mit dem, ich spiele jetzt nur noch selbst Fußball oder eben, ich gucke jetzt wirklich, ich gehe dann zum Club um die Ecke.
Vielleicht habe ich jetzt die Lösung dann doch noch gefunden und das passt dann auch perfekt zum Schluss dieser Episode. Ihr konsumiert einfach Bundesliga und all diese Weltmeisterschaften da draußen nicht mehr direkt, sondern nur noch über den Rasenfunk und dadurch, dass ich ja werbefrei bleibe, wodurch, wozu ich mich übrigens wieder ausdrücklich bekräftigt fühle durch Lektüre dieses Buches, könnte euch sicher sein, es guckt dann nur einer und nicht eine Million und ihr hört dann einfach alle den Rasenfunk. Da freue ich mich. Ich zahle meine Steuern. Das wollen wir mit den 50 Euro.
Du machst das mit den 50 Euro auch nicht, ja?
Nein, mache ich nicht. Ich habe einen Steuerberater, dem das wichtigste Ding ist, was ich ihm immer sage, ist, bitte machen sie es einfach nur korrekt. Ich habe keine Lust auf diese ganzen kleineren Tricks, die man da machen kann. Das ist mir ehrlich gesagt auch zu anstrengend. Football Leaks heißt das Buch von Rafael Buschmann und Michael Wulzinger, ist erschienen im Random House Verlag. Ihr solltet es alles lesen. Ich danke ganz, ganz herzlich zum einen Rafael Buschmann bei Twitter at rafanelli, Autor vom Spiegel. Rafael, vielen Dank, dass du dir Zeit genommen hast.
Vielen Dank. Hat mir sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Euch alles Gute und bis bald.
Ja, danke. Außerdem vielen herzlichen Dank an Nicole Selmer, stellvertretende Chefredakteurin vom Fußballmagazin Ballesterer, bei Twitter at nick-haha. Vielen Dank, Nicole. Und euch, liebe Hörer, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Kauft euch das Buch Football Leaks. Lest. Es geht um Dietmar Hopp, Dinamo Zagreb, Twente Enschede, Mino Raiola, Halilovic, Gaginovic. Ganz viele Themen, die wir jetzt gar nicht ansprechen konnten. Auch noch einige kritische Themen gegenüber den Machern von Football Leaks. Das alles sollte nur ein kleiner Einblick sein. Und ich glaube auch, es war nicht das letzte Tribünengespräch zum Thema. In diesem Sinne werdet Rasenfunk-Supporter und bis bald. Macht's gut.
Das war das Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch. Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.